- I'm not kidding.
It's hard for me, and I told you this,
I said, it's hard for me, to like,
when people come on this show,
to fit in watching everything
that everybody does
'cause I have four
children, and a lot of jobs.
But I was in Montana this
weekend and I got to watch.
It was snowing there, and I got to watch
your new movie Let It Snow.
It is so good.
- Yay!
- It is so good.
It's so cute.
It did remind me of Love Actually,
almost like a new version,
but it's like younger,
it's like a little different but it kinda
reminded me of that.
Do you get that a lot?
- Yeah, it kind of has a nostalgic vibe,
and it does feel like
it's the updated version
of Love Actually in a lot
of ways because, I mean,
that movie stands the
test of time for a reason.
People love it.
People love that kind of format.
But this is new characters,
it's very 2019, 2020,
all the references that
are made are very current.
- And it feels like a younger vibe.
- Yeah, besides the holiday aspect,
it's just kind of a really good movie.
- So what is it about?
Tell everybody what Let It Snow's about.
- You wanna take this one?
- Sure.
- [Kiernan] Sorry to put
you on the spot like that.
- No, I got this.
I've been practicing all morning.
No.
- Telling yourself in
the mirror constantly.
- You're good enough, you're smart enough.
- You're beautiful, you are valid.
- I feel like I'm at the therapist.
Okay, so pretty much--
- Just lean into those feelings.
I'm just kidding, I'm just kidding.
- Okay, I'm gonna try not to cry.
So this whole cast is
full of really, really
awesome young talented people
who I've grown up watching as well.
Like you on Mad Men, Jacob in Spiderman,
we got Odea, and just
really awesome people.
Shameik from Spiderman as well.
And they're all coming together for this
separate but also united love story
about different coming
of age characters who-
my character, personally,
I love and I can relate
to her story because her mother
is going through something
and they have this special bond,
and they actually reference the parents
in this high school movie which is rare.
They have parents and they're around.
- That's funny, I've
never thought of that.
They usually aren't.
It's like, oh I guess
they just get free reign.
- And it's great, and I fall in-
well, no, I don't wanna
spoil anything but yeah.
- It's a Christmas movie.
We know where it's going.
- I fall in a ditch.
Lots of falling in this movie.
- There actually are quite
a few stunts in the movie.
There's a lot of falling.
- Then there's Joan Cusack is in it, too.
- I love her.
How funny is her character?
- [Tim] Oh, I know him.
- No, you know John.
- Joan.
- or her.
Her as well, see.
- John and Joan.
- Someone in my age group
is what I was thinking.
- Hey, I'm with you, I'm
37, but I enjoyed it.
They were like, when I came in the room,
they were like, yeah, it's
kind of a young little thing,
and I was like, wait,
well, I'm 37, I liked it.
I thought it was really good.
No, but John and Joan are great,
but Joan is hilarious.
Her character is so good,
but it's also heartfelt.
She's very like heartfelt.
- Yeah, she's a legend.
- Do you have any favorite
traditions like for Christmas
that you do with your
families or anything?
- Yeah, I do.
It's a little offbeat, little off center.
But it's a tradition in our family,
and I think it comes from their traditions
that they brought to America from Peru.
It's a little crazy.
So what you do is you take a napkin
and you tuck it behind
the person who's playing-
you tuck it in their
pants like a little tail,
like a little tail.
Then you light it on fire.
And you play a song and they
have to shake their butt
and put out the fire before
the song is over or else-
well, before their pants catch on fire.
(laughter)
- Before it leaves a scar.
- What?
(laughter)
Wait, what is this?
Is this a tradition?
Are they running from some-
are you escaping a spirit?
Like what's--
- It's all in fun spirit.
It's all fun-spirited.
It's not menacing at all.
It's like, but basically if you don't know
how to shake your butt, you can't play.
- You know what, I'm in.
This mama can shake her tail
feather, so I'm good, I'm in.
Wait, do you have any ones
that might put you in the ER?
- I mean, I'm Irish Catholic
so like guilt I guess?
(applause)
- Oh my God!
We just all sit around and
go, I could've done better.
Tim, do you have any?
- I'm Irish Italian, so
guilt's probably involved too.
- We've got fire and guilt.
What are you bringing to the table?
- I'm bringing pasta to the table.
- Oh, I love it.
- Well, since we were
kids, my mom's maiden name
is D'Agostino so since we were kids,
we've always had spaghetti
and meatballs Christmas Eve.
So we still do it.
Everybody looks forward to it.
And everybody comes to our house
and we have a big spaghetti
and meatball dinner.
- You should throw some
garlic bread in there.
- Well, we do, we do.
The whole deal.
- It probably doesn't go with your thing
that you're doing now.
- Oh, I eat plenty when it comes to that.
- You eat bread?
Oh God.
I hate men.
Men, it's so easy.
It's just easier for y'all.
I can't stand you right now.
So wait, and you also have
a song named Papi, right?
Where did the song come from?
- So I wrote the song about
this guy I worked with.
Basically he was very
obsessed with the idea
that I was Latina and he
would learn these phrases
in Spanish that were-
he just was asking to
get punched in the face.
- Yeah.
He's trying too hard.
- I didn't, but instead, you know,
one day I called his
name, I called him over,
and he was like, no, don't call me that.
Call me papi.
And I'm like what?
I cringed all the way down to my toes
and I said I'm gonna
write a song about that.
'Cause he inspired it.
- Cause you're a tool.
- Yeah, pretty much.
- As a father of three daughters,
just go ahead and punch him too.
(laughter)
- Oh my God, you're so my husband.